please listen to me mate
I swear to fuck
Google the name
just Google how does he
why does he do that
by Lundy Bancroft
PDF versions are available online
the first time I read that book
it was a PDF and I had it on my phone
and I would literally be like
reading it while he was next to me
and then I would be getting scared cause I'd be like
oh my god cause the book really helps you understand the mind of somebody
as many times as you're like no no no
I know he doesn't mean it
no he's just having a hard day
no I know he's just tired
he says he's that
then how come he knows how to not scream at his fucking boss
when his boss says something
how come when you're out at a restaurant and somebody does something
he never acts this way in public
he knows what the fuck he's doing
this book if you've ever been like
I just don't know how to leave
I don't know how to leave
this book will fucking fix it
and you don't need to buy it
it's available for free online
Google why does he do that PDF
it will come up
you don't have to buy it
please please
just like read it
thumb through it
just read a couple of sentences
I promise you
that shit will wake you up